Welcome to another Stories From The
Stores
now today I'm joined by curator Donata Miller
and she says it's time to show me something very interesting, so Donata what's this?
This is a Chinese powdered incense clock.
It's a clock that uses
incense and fire to tell the time.
It's from the 1700s onwards. Initially
incense clocks would be used in temples
to tell the time with festivals or
when certain ceremonies needs to take place.
Okay so with incense clocks they
all have this really cool symbol in the middle?
So not all incense clocks have this symbol,
but the modern incense clocks would often have a symbol of luck or goodwill in the middle.
This is a character which is called 双喜 (shuāngxǐ)
and it's a character which has been
translated to mean Double Happiness
It's a character which is often used
in Chinese culture and often related to marriage.
Something that scholars would
often use to feel inspired,
smoke would come through the grates and it would trigger their emotions and imaginations.
Okay so you've talked about how it works, can you show me?
This clock has two different levels here and it shows us a little maze inside.
We have these mazes, there's one that's more simple and one that's more complex
These mazes would tell different amounts of time.
You would use white words ash or you could also
use powdered incense to lay a layer on
the tray and then press the maze imprint
into this white wood ash and that
would leave a trail for you to light and measure the time that it is.
Okay so you watch it, just watch it burn is what you do?
You can watch it burn but you can
smell it burning also.
Depending on the material that you've put inside, you'd be able to smell it.
So what you're telling me is I could just know it's
11:15 because the room smells like roses?
Basically yes!
So why do you think it's so important that the museum has something like this?
I think it shows a type of time measurement that we're not used to seeing
and it really shows that
Western culture doesn't own time
and that people from different cultures
and different societies have been
telling time in many different ways for
a very very long time.